-Attorney General
Merrick Garland announced
that he has appointed
a special counsel to oversee
the Justice Department's
investigations
of former
President Donald Trump
and Trump has responded
by spending the last few days
whining that he is a victim
of political persecution.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
If you watch this show,
I'm sure you're aware
that Donald Trump announced
his third run
for the presidency last week.
In fact, if you watch this show
and, somehow,
you are unaware of that fact,
I would like to know
who you are.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, this show is basically
the local news Santa Tracker,
but for Donald Trump.
[ Laughter ]
Point is,
you know he's running again,
but I still feel like
I might have to tell you
because it just seems
different, this time.
For example, you may have
noticed that Trump's message
and even his demeanor
during his announcement
were quite a departure
from his first run back in 2016.
Let's compare the central themes
of his first campaign from 2016
and this one.
-I, alone, can fix it.
I'm a victim.
I will tell you.
[ Laughter ]
I'm a victim.
-Quite the hero's journey.
[ Laughter ]
He went
from "I, alone, can fix it"
to "I am a victim."
[ Laughter ]
That's like Superman flying
into a bank to stop a robbery,
only to come out with his
underpants on his head, crying,
"There were like five bad guys
in there.
[ Laughter ]
Why didn't anyone give me
a heads-up?"
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, who is this message
supposed to appeal to?
Does Trump think people
will vote for him
because they feel bad for him?
I wouldn't be surprised
if his first campaign ad was one
of those ASPCA commercials,
[ Laughter ]
except, instead of your
money going to animals,
it goes to him.
[ As Trump ]
In the arms of --
[ Laughter ]
In the arms of an angel.
So true, so true.
[ Laughter ]
You know, I met an angel, once.
He was an ethereal being
of pure energy and light.
Big angel, strong angel.
[ Laughter ]
Came up to me,
tears pouring down
[ Laughter ]
his glowing, radiant angel face
and he knelt down next to me
and he laid his hand
upon my shoulder
and he said to me,
"Donald, wake up.
It's Rudy. You fell asleep
during the meeting."
[ Laughter ]
And I said, "I was wondering why
my angel smelled
like Scotch farts."
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, click here to donate.
Someone get this [bleep] dog
away from me.
[ Laughter and applause ]
By the way,
if you thought the contrast
between those two speeches
was striking,
you're not the only one.
Even Fox Business noticed
the difference,
during an interview with Trump's
daughter-in-law Lara Trump,
who seemed caught off-guard
by the question.
-I have to say that there wasn't
a great reception
to the speech last night.
Not a single elected
Republican official was there.
How do you feel about it?
You were there, so, I'm sure
you're very supportive
of your father-in-law...
-[ Nervous laugh ]
...but those of us on the
outside, looking at it,
it didn't seem
as he got the old magic.
You know what I mean?
-Oh, well, I highly
disagree with that.
-Wow. If you're a member
of the Trump family,
you are not used to getting
tough questions on Fox Business.
[ Laughter ]
That's like Ryan Gosling getting
grilled on the red carpet.
"Really, Ryan, a white tux?
Are you attending the
Golden Globes, or catering them?
Ya burnt!"
[ Laughter ]
You could tell
she was unprepared
for such a hostile reception
because she did
that awkward chuckle
halfway through the question,
like your mom
passive-aggressively fighting
with your dad at Thanksgiving.
"Honey, is this turkey
intentionally dry?
[ Laughing ]
Because it's so well done."
That's funny, Richard.
The way you were flirting
with Maria,
I assumed you like
dried-up old birds.
[ Laughter and oohs ]
Richard, ya burnt.
[ Laughter ]
But that is the core
of Trump's message
and of GOP ideology --
performative victimhood.
And that fake victimhood only
got more ridiculous on Friday,
when the attorney general,
Merrick Garland,
announced that he was appointing
a special counsel
to oversee the department's
investigations of Donald Trump.
-I'm here today to announce
the appointment
of a special counsel
in connection with two ongoing
criminal investigations
that have received
significant public attention.
The first, as described
in court filings
in the District of Columbia,
is the investigation
into whether any person
or entity
unlawfully interfered
with the transfer of power
following the 2020
presidential election
or the certification of the
Electoral College vote held
on or about January 6, 2021.
The second is
the ongoing investigation
involving classified documents
and other presidential records,
as well as the possible
obstruction
of that investigation,
referenced and described
in court filings,
in a pending matter in the
Southern District of Florida.
-I like how he never says
Trump's name, once,
in that clip, but you know
who he's talking about.
[ Laughter ]
Garland couldn't have been any
more specific, if he tried.
[ As Garland ]
I am here today to announce the
appointment of a special counsel
in connection
with an investigation
into whether
presidential records
were illegally retained
by any individual,
specifically sweaty, loudmouthed
real estate moguls from New York
[ Laughter ]
who own chintzy resorts
in Palm Beach
and don't know how to close
a [bleep] umbrella.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's back, baby!
The umbrella video is back!
You run again, we play
the umbrella video again.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Them's the rules!
So, if you're keeping track
at home,
we're now in our second
special counsel looking
into whether Donald Trump,
a notoriously corrupt
criminal authoritarian
dip[bleep], broke any laws.
And by the way, the special
counsel Garland appointed is
a guy named Jack Smith,
who, by all accounts,
and also by his name,
another no-nonsense,
tough-as-nails prosecutor
who will follow the facts
and won't be intimidated,
which is the same thing
they said about Robert Mueller,
which is cool, I guess,
but where did that get us?
I mean, Mueller outlined
ten different allegations
of obstruction of justice,
not to mention actual proof
that Trump's campaign
openly welcomed
and encouraged foreign
interference in the election
and then all Trump had to do
was lean into the mic and say...
-Wrong.
[ Laughter ]
-...and that was it.
By the way, that's what we here
at "Late Night" call
another classic vid.
[ Laughter ]
[ Electronic voice ]
[ Vuvuzela blasts ]
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I think they had time
to read it.
You know what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
Now, with all that said,
the situation has changed,
this time,
so, there's reason
to be cautiously optimistic
that, maybe,
things will be different.
A former member
of Mueller's team,
Andrew Weissmann, tweeted...
Okay, so, how long should we
give him, a week?
[ Laughter ]
Based on the evidence
that's already public,
he could've interrupted Garland
halfway through the press
conference introducing him.
We're going to give Jack
the time he needs --
"Actually, America,
can I just jump in?
I think I'm good to indict."
[ Laughter ]
I mean, did you see that photo
of all the top secret documents
spread out on his floor?
[ Laughter ]
Pretty sure he left
his fingerprints
in the ketchup blots.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, it won't surprise you
to learn
that Trump immediately
started complaining
about the appointment
of a special counsel
at a gala at Mar-A-Lago
last week after the news broke
and, in usual Trump fashion,
he just went on and on about it.
Also, please enjoy the fact
that he's whining
about all this stuff
while also dressed
like the piano player
at a Long Island steakhouse.
-I want to address
[ Laughter ]
the appalling announcement today
by the egregiously corrupt
Biden administration
and their weaponized
Department of Justice.
Would you like me
to talk about that?
This is a rigged deal,
just as the 2020 election
was rigged,
and we can't let them get
away with it.
I was tried on the fake
impeachment hoax on January 6th
and isn't this sort of like
double jeopardy?
In the old days, they used
to call it double jeopardy.
[ Laughter ]
Why aren't they
investigating all of the other
presidents that preceded me?
-[ As Trump ]
Alright, enough talking.
♪ It was 5:00 ♪
[ Laughter and applause ]
Oh, and also, all?
You want them to investigate all
of the other presidents?
[ Laughter ]
All 44?
[ As Trump ]
Why aren't they investigating
William "The Refrigerator" Taft
[ Laughter ]
or Grovelin' Grover Cleveland
or Lyin' Lincoln?
Lyin' Abe Lincoln.
What's under that hat?
[ Laughter ]
I've said it for years --
look under the hat.
Nobody listened to me.
Nobody looked under the hat.
You don't think he
smuggled documents
out of the White House
in that giant hat?
[ Laughter ]
I guarantee you, if you lifted
that hat off his dumb head,
you'd find an old Civil War
document that says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
In defense of Trump,
I do think it must've been
a little suspicious
when Lincoln started wearing
those giant hats one day.
[ Laughter ]
I don't want to spread
any rumors, but come on.
If your buddy Dale suddenly
started showing up to work
in a stovepipe hat...
[ Laughter ]
...you would think
something was up.
[ Whispering ]
"Psst! Hey, guys, want to know
who took all the free pizza
from the conference room?
[ Laughter ]
Dinner for a week, baby!"
Get outta here, Dale!
We all know it was you.
You stink like pepperoni!
[ Laughter ]
Now, as we told you last week,
Trump's announcement speech
was so boring,
even Fox News cut away from it
before it was over.
And then on Friday,
just to add insult to injury,
the same thing happened
to Trump again,
except, this time,
it was on C-SPAN.
-In Afghanistan,
when I was in charge,
we didn't have one killing.
Think of it.
In 18 months,
not one of our soldiers
were killed.
And then you look at Chicago
and you look
at other [indistinct].
[ Applause ]
-Former President Trump
has moved on
[ Laughter ]
to other topics.
We'll take this opportunity
to move on
with our program schedule.
[ Laughter ]
I would say C-SPAN
just Ya Burnted Trump,
but they can't afford
the graphics.
[ Laughter ]
Even C-SPAN cut away!
This is the network famous
for showing wide shots
of empty chairs
and even they were like,
"This [bleep] is boring."
[ Laughter ]
You know how bad
your speech has to be
for C-SPAN to cut away from it?
You know what their
program schedule was
that they had to get back to?
An old man silently doing
the crossword by himself
for six hours
and then falling asleep.
[ Laughter ]
If our laws are to have
any meaning at all,
then, obviously,
Donald Trump should be indicted.
It shouldn't take six years
and multiple special
counsels to do
and we certainly can't wait
for the Republican Party
to finally decide if they're
willing to turn on Trump
because, while Republicans
are engaged in a family feud,
trying to decide
if the price is right,
our democracy is very much in...
-Jeopardy.
-Oh, boy.
[ Laughter ]
Guys, I saw it coming.
I didn't know how to stop it.
[ Laughter ]
This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]